you never saw any of the Star Wars no
not one but insane am I missing out do
you think it's great it's so great I
love it what do you think it's about
Star Wars yeah what do you think it is
yeah that's very good it's what do you
think Star Wars what it has to be about
yeah is yeah
Intergalactic War exactly yeah there we
go right so with do you know anything
are you joking for real what do you mean
is is it about that
well uh dude it's not about like Star
Wars it's not about soccer okay oh yeah
yeah I mean you took the it's obvious
Star Wars yeah that's a war going on
okay right so what I'm gonna ask you is
do you know some of the characters in
your mind already
um pop culture Luke you're right so just
tell me the story then just tell me the
story what you think happens
I mean you gotta have a antagonist so
start with Luke what is he
um is he the hero of the antagonist he's
the hero exactly he's a hero tell me
about him Prince so he goes out and he
is doing his thing you know what I mean
he's doing his thing of course of course
I get it
yeah you're trying to just hold it down
because you know he's working for his
uncle Owen yeah right and there's like
farming to do is there farming to do up
there
all of a sudden he's out farming yes and
then freaking princess Leila comes into
the picture
yeah it's kind of stuff
either yeah hey Luke oh she's there Luke
yeah she's there yeah yeah yeah
um My Goats they need hay you know and
then that just spins into a day in day
out kind of you know they just keep
running into each other and then and
then she just probably ends up ruining
it she does ruin it does she yeah she
ruins it yeah so it took eight movies
and wait what was the princess's name
did you say Layla rice is
yeah and describe her hairstyle bra no
no she's calling you bro
that's right come on all right so and
then how does Darth Vader
wow we're talking we're talking now this
is where it gets real interesting right
yeah yeah because it does right people
don't know uh-huh till this day yeah oh
you know some insights too they don't
know the connection of of
princess Leila and Darth they really
don't and what's the connection
dude you want to keep looking here dude
I love this [__] guy what's the
connection I'm telling you it's it's
it's I mean I know we both know but like
yeah for the viewers yeah so for those
of you who got talking to you guys
um it's just it's one of those things
where
you really wouldn't believe
unless unless yeah unless you read the
script but I I read it I read the script
right right yeah the outtakes what is it
what is it
she actually yeah designs
the call the costumes for him wait what
what
let's think about that think about it
look okay so my question to you
he has a one costume
for everything yeah so that one costume
she designed when was it made right
right when was it made think about it
think about it so could I just say
something to you because I've seen the
movie many times okay okay you might not
know this right how off was was that how
accurate was that well first of all um
not accurate at all really yeah because
um it would be impossible for her to
design
the daughter suit since she's right a
little daughter of Darth Vader and he
had the costume see before she was born
two are brothers and sisters Leia or
layla it's Leia ooh yeah yeah the
hairstyle you got down okay yeah yeah
yeah so um yeah I just don't think I
don't know how I know I don't know what
script you read yeah from George Lucas
or whatever notes but that would be
impossible right okay yeah yeah because
he had the suit because
um um Obi-Wan they get another five
knobs
yeah so if you were on like Tatooine and
you saw Ben Kenobi you call him yeah
yeah okay yeah and be like Oh Z all
right right yeah so that's pretty good
so that's so let me ask you something
did you never want us to watch it or
you know I was just too busy watching
freaking Goonies and apocalypse oh [__]
like yeah Apocalypto Apocalypto that's
Mel Gibson yeah that's a great movie
dude how much times have you watched it
there is give me one